cazzo ti prego ti prego non farmi del
male che spera
se non ha ancora iniziato hanno
incorniciato
si sono alzate facciamo così provata
aspetta io ti dico via quando tutto ti
dico di
sì no no no no aspetta aspetta non me la
sento
diciamo riguarda ho trenta minuti di
pausa sono disperata lo so lo so che non
ho prenotato però deve assolutamente
aiutarmi su una cliente affezionata
riuscirai pur a trovarmi un posticino
allora devo fare poco mezza gamba
inguine ascelle viso mani piedi e
massaggio drenante se riesci no io
guarda cioè non la soffro per niente la
ceretta cioè me lo dicono tutte
l'estetista una soglia del dolore
proprio altissima ma adesso vedrai
guarda
[Musica]
non mi hai fatto niente
anzi guarda sono così rilassata che
canto il
ft
car a una domanda da quant'è che fare se
vista no perché ti spiego io ho fatto
tre mesi di scuola di specchi ca è la
prima cosa mi hanno insegnato e come
fare lo strappo in questa zona
dammi un attimo che ti faccio vedere
allora vedi tu lo 20 così ok e poi lo
fai da questo dato qui è diverso
rispetto a quello facevi tu ma poi anche
la mano c'è un pò pesante c'era un
traghetto che bisogna parlavano brigate
leggera per fare l'estetista
prossima volta me la faccio da sola no
dicevo continuatore ciao cara io devo
fare mezza gamba però adesso vedrai ho
veramente pochissimi veri cioè non mi
fare prezzo intero family almeno la metà
al fine ai meno lavoro da fare
liguria famoso belo sgommato se ancora
un po stai ancora un po ci siamo quasi
ma ancora un pochino e la faccia tutta
questa no tutta non la voglio fare di
porano no troppo too much ancora un po
ancora un pochino poco poco però mi
sembra brutto lasciare solo un pero no a
dai bambola tutta bella liscia amici
oggi sono a fare la ceretta dalla mia
lista preferita chiami dalla mia amata
katia saluta ciao adoro
no è sto andando le foto di un nuovo
ragazzo si faccia scegliere come la
buona è capito che carina come idea
ciao io ho prenotato la mia prima
ceretta per le 16 e 30 senti ma fa tanto
male ma più o meno da 1 a 10 quanto fa
male ma la cera e tanto calda settima se
invece continuassi a fare il rasoio no
perché un po paura ti nero se ti faccio
male a nome tranquilla tanto non sento
nulla
sarò abbiamo finito
ha già finito bravissimo sei stata
velocissima beata te che non senti nulla
non state volatile col tempo belli mi
sono anche rilassato non del 30
fra sole
o meglio che trento ma hai acceso
lettino a non avete lettini riscaldati o
che io sono frettolosa da mila coperta
no tesoro lacerato pò calata su morendo
scotta leva mela oddio ma mi vuoi
mission aree
e ti sarò
guarda guarda bene c'è un pelo non è
strappato mi raccomando farci poco di
attenzione e una pianta dell'altra
guarda si esatta 20 di un millimetro si
è pronto per si accorge teletu insomma
il tè lavoro ma è una mia pressione o
sulla luce c'è un bruttissimo peletto
rimasto
trapano podio non hai capito cosa ti
devo raccontare allora noemi che la
sorella di sara che lavora al bar di
fronte qui davanti mi ha raccontato che
valeria valeri e stata servita dalle tv
ma non è il corneto come l'ha scoperto
mi è passato davanti al computer del
marito trovato tutte le spinte con
questa ma cosi tipo beautiful perché lei
anche sposate a quattro figli che ho
capito è stata suu kyi ha voce perché
c'è un'alta clienti nella cabina a
fianco c'è simone la mia amica parlo
forte così mi senti però amo hai sentito
mica allucinante infatti no ma ma poi
non hai capito e cioè se fosse successo
a me mikel aver bruciato la macchina nel
cristo solo il divorce cioè che signora